Вітаю вас друзі з початком нового
навчального року Так цей навчальний рік
є першим з часів завершення Другої
світової війни який ми на жаль
розпочинаємо в умовах воєнного стану
саме тому основне завдання на якому
сконцентрувало свої зусилля Міністерства
освіти і науки України це зробити для
вас всіх освітній процес доступним
безперервним та максимально безпечним ми
розуміємо як ви всі скучили за своїми
друзями
однокласниками вчителями і хочете
повернутися до своїх класів для цього ми
в тих регіонах де це можливо і дозволяє
безпекова ситуація рекомендуємо очне
навчання
забезпечивши школи бомбосховищами
але остаточний вибір формату навчання чи
очного чи дистанційного буде за вами
вашими батьками а також місцевою владою
для тих хто сьогодні знаходиться за
межами країни Ми також надаємо
можливість навчатися за українською
програмою для цього розгортається мережа
українських освітніх хабабах в рамках
міжнародної української школи а також
працюють в Польщі Німеччині
Великобританії і Ми продовжуємо
відкривати такі хаби в інших країнах
світу де наразі перебувають українські
учні
незважаючи на те Який формат навчання ви
оберете ми докладаємо всіх зусиль щоб
зробити цей навчальний рік не тільки
цікавим а й корисним для вас всі
п'ятикласники в цьому році вперше
розпочнуть навчання за новою програмою в
рамках реформи нової української школи
також на вас чекають багато приємних
нових можливостей
це і вивчення іноземних мов за
інноваційними методами і уроків
фізкультури по-новому і нове харчування
і можливість свідомого вибору майбутньої
професії та багато чого іншого над чим
Ми продовжуємо працювати навіть під час
жорсткої війни Російської Федерації
проти нашої держави хочу подякувати
нашим учням які складали в цьому році
національний мультиппредметний тест
майже 10 тисяч учасників тестування
отримали найвищі 200 балів хоча б з
одного з предметів а майже 3000 отримали
по 200 балів з кожного з трьох предметів
ціми результатами
ви не лише розвіяли сумніви експертів
а й переконливо продемонстрували що всі
Громадяни України мають володіти
українською мовою та знати історію
України
незважаючи на те до якого тестування
готувалися пишаємось з вами Ви як і ми
дорослі Незламні ви гідні майбутнє нашої
держави
І сьогодні я звертаюсь до кожного з вас
повертайтесь до навчання адже саме вам
відбудовувати та розвивати наше
Прекрасну незалежну країну
Вірте в себе ставте перед собою
максимально амбітні цілі і ви
обов'язково їх досягнете усім освітянам
щиро дякую за відданість професії За
мужність і стійкість ви герої освітнього
фронту саме ви формуєте сьогодні еліту
нашої процвітаючою держави бажаю вам
міцного здоров'я миру злагоди і
невичерпано натхнення розвиватися та
змінювати Україну на краще зі святом вас
тримаємось ми сильні ми Україна З
повагою до вас Разом до перемоги